born argentina the crazy story with me
is like my mom
smuggled me and my sister in through the
mexican border
with coyotes what the
[ __ ] are we talking about right now i
was three years old my mom my sister my
younger sister was
one and she brought us into the mexican
border illegally
i didn't become a citizen until like
seven years ago
like they should have built a wall you
know what those [ __ ] did
dude i barely made the gun barely made
the cut
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast
new episode with a new guest uh you guys
might know him from the interwebs
music acting what else do you do man
what don't you do is the question bro it
is like the new age
uh immigrant struggle like working
multiple jobs you know this is the
version of that like you too
that's dead ass you know like our
parents like we work three jobs like
we have a podcast we actually do this i
know that's what that is
this is uh it's jonathan do you just go
by jonathan partner you still go by
dumbfounded uh john park or dumb
dumbfounded you know you flipped a
different name uh midway
what the [ __ ] was that about every
[ __ ] always brings this up and
i'm like ah damn
you should have texted us first i was
like yo what it is is like i was getting
older and i was like
and dumbfounded is a hard name to like
introduce people
you know because i get it like if you
have an
artist's name you can stretch it out for
longer no one even bats an eye like like
ludicrous right you're like fabulous
those are funny names in hindsight but
like they've had a strong career
and the same for me but i kind of i
think it was the era where a lot of
rappers were going by like
real names you know like kendrick lamar
okay like you know what i mean like
you're like what am i doing i was like
damn bro like
wacky rap names aren't in anymore i like
your name was so iconic though you know
it was fun i think it matched me because
i did a lot of humorous [ __ ]
with my raps so i tried to change my
name to parker
for like that's what it was that was the
biggest mistake you've ever made
it might have slowed down my career for
a good two years
when i saw that they pop up i'm like who
the [ __ ] is this so yeah i did that and
i got the same reaction that you just
had from everybody
and they were like no you're not
going to change that or give us a heads
up right you know who actually did that
too was uh
the young filipino dude from canada yeah
yeah
yeah uh russell russell right i had him
on the podcast russell's dope
and i think the crazy thing that he
found out was because he didn't give
anybody a heads up
they just thought he died yeah they
legit thought he died russell went from
[ __ ] kids bop to
he got face tattooed
that was his thing when he was on the
podcast he was talking about it was
either he was going to be all in or not
and i think because you started off as a
young as a young kid rapper
he was always stuck with that image and
nobody took his music as seriously as he
thought
i feel for him because he was a prodigy
you know i mean he was like a young
child prodigy of music and like
i think when you start from that
situation it gets kind of tough you feel
like you have so much to prove as you
get older you can't
break your image of the child you know
youtube star
and uh he's leaned into what heavy i
would say i mean for you too
because like there was a shift in your
music right because i've been listening
to you for
quite a while since we met and then all
of a sudden your music style shifted
and it was weird because i'm i'm i'm
observing these comments right for me
yeah when i saw that shift i enjoyed it
a lot right because you were doing a lot
of
uh underground hip-hop type of [ __ ] like
backpack hip-hop right
so when i was listening to that stuff
i'm like when's the next evolution gonna
happen when it happened
you kind of had mixed reviews there was
like i really [ __ ] with it and there
were some people like i missed the old
dumbfounded i think a lot of people you
know it's it's like all of youtube too
and comedy too right like people have
podcasts now it's not all sketches
you know what i'm saying i mean you come
from doing sketches you come from
commentary
and now you do pods and it's just all
part of the game you know what i mean
and bro like i'm i'm over 30 years
old you know what i'm saying and my
whole thing is
i think when rap like rapping and the
content of it
it's hard to talk about things like as
you get older
it that's the big challenge for me like
i started rapping because i
liked the arrogant like ignorant energy
but when you get older and things do get
serious like
i think that's why i have a struggle
with like constantly
like rapping because i don't want to
necessarily rap about serious [ __ ]
that's like old and grown yeah and like
what do you do at that point right like
you're stuck because you do this thing
that you love
like rap but you don't necessarily want
to rap about
responsible [ __ ] yeah like i started
because i want to rap about
dumb [ __ ] yeah and like and i'm not
saying it was all
dumb but it was like a youthful kind of
fun energy yeah you know and
and i think that's the problem like i
don't want to necessarily rap about
responsibilities
i don't know i mean i mean everybody has
that weird i think that's what i
appreciated about
uh like kanye like not a single album
that he did was like the other one
before it
right and sometimes when people kind of
deviate from this idea of the person
that they love they start to hate that
idea
but at the same time it's like if i
stuck doing the same thing would you
still be listening to my stuff three or
four years later you probably get
[ __ ] tired of it
right so that's that's like that weird
part too i feel like
i think that's why i appreciate when
artists change a little bit because it's
still
in the essence of the same person that
you still listen to they're just trying
something new
right and so when you made that change i
actually thought it was better than the
previous stuff that you had before in my
personal opinion
yeah i i you know i always say like
early on
i got into the rap game really early and
i was breaking rules before i learned
the rules
so a lot of my music early on was really
sloppy like hooks and raps like
everything was like out of pocket like
it's things just sounded really sloppy
but the topics and the weird things that
i was doing with that
like was interesting and people
resonated towards that but the thing is
i didn't learn the rules like of
how to structure bars and and do hooks
and stuff
that was the biggest change in your
music was the hooks yeah right so
everything i learned like i learned
everything later on the rules and
everything so
i don't understand how it is important
to at least learn the rules and the
foundation
before you start breaking you know what
i'm saying like people always
people think by breaking rules i i'm i'm
saying like i'm
when i'm saying don't break the rules i
they think like oh like do it this
certain way no i'm saying learn the
foundation
and then break the rules after you learn
it you know what i'm saying because
trust me i went office away and it takes
a long time that way well you're one of
those few people too that
goes from like i'm not disrupt
disrespecting any battle rappers out
there
but i kind of am because your music
sucks dick like usually
the the battle rapper doesn't really get
to do a lot of great music because
they're so used to doing so many
bars and [ __ ] one-line hitters that
when it comes to writing music there's a
story to be told there's an ebb and flow
to it right when it comes to the verse
to the hook and everything else i'm not
saying it's not all battle rappers are
like well to be fair like dude all
battle rappers don't want to necessarily
make music
either so it's not like but when they do
it's pretty bad
i didn't know it well i think yeah i
don't know i feel like sometimes battle
rappers when they were making
trying to try to make music you know
because obviously they didn't put out a
lot of music they'll put out like
one song here one song there i think
it's because
there was this thing like we're supposed
to go into making music
now battle rap is like no you couldn't
actually just battle rap
yeah it's okay to do that you know what
i'm saying but there was this pressure a
while back because like oh you're just
gonna battle rap
and i i hate those kind of pressures i
think in anything you do right like if
someone wants to just do stand up and
not all break into acting like
that should be okay you know what i'm
saying like i don't like these artist
pressure things like oh dumb you haven't
done this in forever or that like who
gives a [ __ ] that's my [ __ ] like you
know what i'm saying and
i think when you let those things get to
you it's gonna drive you crazy it's
really gonna torment you for a long time
as an artist
yeah you know i mean those those yeah
that is kind of true though because i
always did expect a battle rapper to
make music because they always
what people would always say is like oh
he could battle but can't he [ __ ]
make music but that's what i'm saying no
one thinks like
does he even want to make music you
didn't even ask me yeah like you didn't
even
like right now you just thought the same
thing right you didn't even think that
you might not want to make me because
because for me it's like because rap is
always going to be considered music to
me so i i
i assume that that is the general step
the reason why they battle rap is
because they wanted to do music i get
you and there are there's a lot but i'm
saying
it's not there's people who literally
just do do that
yeah you know it was a weird scene too
because i remember when uh
when battle rap was there was no music
like the music is gone
it's there's no music anymore and then
people started going into the argument
of like well why don't you do that to a
[ __ ] beat though
yeah but to me it's like it kind of
makes sense because
beats wise there's so many sub-genres of
hip-hop
yeah right there's like boom back
there's trap you know there's all these
different tempos
and and bpm's and all that it's like
what how do you choose that for a battle
yeah you know what i'm saying so
i i think this one the reason it went
acapella it's more universal
yeah yeah yeah it definitely allowed uh
a lot of different people to start doing
it right like we don't have to be on
beat
yeah i'm almost i couldn't write a bit
of [ __ ]
we're like okay and it was it was weird
too because i i think the
the weirdest thing was when i saw a lot
of white boys do it right and they
started adding their own little
nerdy rap flow to it and they were they
started killing people
yeah because it's like well [ __ ]
i actually read so
i have a lot of words on deck there were
a lot of these little
like witty witty like nerdy dudes uh
i mean i was one of them really like the
asian witty guy you know but there was
also like
super witty uh nerdy white dudes that
came in the game
and um but and they would even flip like
the gangster
[ __ ] like the gun bars yeah you know
what i'm saying but they'll do research
on the gun
yeah what type of gun is this
like these [ __ ] was yeah coming
in and it's weird it's still
going you know what i'm saying and
they're long and and now
it's more advanced that i feel like well
they made it into like a
profitable market people were started
making money off of this stuff yeah
like i think there was a uh i'm even
when jen was doing it back in the day
right like people were battle rapping
but
the platform wasn't as big like when you
when you did that battle against uh
conceded
that [ __ ] was huge like i was shocked
how big that function was through that
battle
that's [ __ ] nice yeah yeah drake and
i think battle rapping has always been
like this
it's not necessarily profitable where
like mad people watching they're just
throwing money at it
but the few rich ass [ __ ] that
do watch it
like throw money at it and they like
don't expect a return
they're just like i [ __ ] with this like
like drake like drake funded that whole
battle
and like i'm pretty sure like he didn't
really make much money back you know
what i'm saying but
he supported the culture he's like no i
don't know if it's that but
he supports the culture you know what i
mean and we i think
for anything like that like subcultures
like that you need
just people who really [ __ ] with the
vision you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah
just on a profit level but just know
that those things just need to
exist in the fabric of the culture you
know what i really do appreciate about
like battle rap though it's like a time
capsule like they still say the words
[ __ ]
like i'm like yikes i will say
battle rap is one of the last places
where like political correctness does
not exist i'm not saying i appreciate
that people could continually say what
i'm saying is like
what i said i just kind of take a step
like hold on a second i mean get
canceled
i have i have you know old epis uh old
battles where i've said
[ __ ] before yeah and and it's it's
crazy like i look at him like [ __ ] i
can't believe this on the internet it's
almost like the comedy space
what it used to be right right like if
you're if the objective in the battle is
to
[ __ ] destroy somebody you got to say
some hateful ass [ __ ]
yeah so that's the purpose of what it is
yeah but i think you can definitely you
know
beat somebody now without without saying
that yeah without saying it was just a
different time we all know this we don't
got to go into that but
it was a different time and but it's
funny because there's still rappers who
do say that yeah and sometimes when i
hear it's so funny because we grew up in
an era where it was okay
but when i look back at it now and i
hear the word it makes me cringe now it
does
make me hurt my feelings it's one of
those words that a lot of people at the
time could just
you know say well you said it for just
anything
yeah even if you like somebody like good
morning [ __ ]
it was a wow like yeah i'm your mom
it was just but like yeah and now
like i can't even say it like i've
actually even said the f word
just be like the f word i know that's
crazy i know i know i've said it
because to me it's like not all
environments sometimes i could feel
comfortable just
at least explaining it by saying [ __ ]
yeah but sometimes i'll say the f word
if i'm in a certain environment
you know like it's like a reading the
room kind of thing yeah you know like
i'll go into like meetings
like i mean you're very you're very
transparent i am too
but it's like there's always a time
where everyone
has to read the room in a situation oh a
hundred percent you know what i'm saying
like
you don't go to board meetings and [ __ ]
saying some wild [ __ ]
yeah or you would think you're right or
you don't want to see you in a board
meeting yeah yeah you [ __ ] go up
well it's weird because you know when i
started
you know youtube for me was always a
transition for me to get into something
else right
but i think what what i didn't expect
out of that was
how much of a business this machine is
right so in my mind i'm like oh i'm just
gonna
be myself and then see whatever the [ __ ]
happens now mind you
half the time that works the other half
people just want you to play ball
right and so the the other half where
they want you to play ball is where i
always run into trouble right so it's
like i'm
i tend to be hyper vocal even when i
don't have to be so right
you know that was the the difficult part
of me because after we i did the film
i was like okay and that's it's funny
that you brought that up about the whole
the rapper or the the battle rapper that
goes in the music like nobody asked like
does he even want to do music right and
after i did the film i'd even ask myself
do i want to be an actor i was like well
let's do this
you know and then i was doing i'm like
do i want to be like a television actor
i didn't even think about that right it
just that opportunity just came to me
and i was like okay well let's just see
if something's going to happen or not
yeah you know i think
i mean for you you probably just all
around like entertainment
so it's it's not really you didn't feel
like you're separating the two into two
different things
yeah it felt like the same thing for you
and you know it was it was a personal
story so it was
in all honesty it was easier for me to
act it out because it was my story right
yeah i mean it was stuff that i grew up
with stuff that i grew up around with
obviously not in k-town but the
the asian kid in the store yeah so it
was it was something that was within my
wheelhouse and a story that i wanted to
tell
so now you take that person and you say
hey well you're gonna have to be in this
abc sitcom where you play
this uh this asian kid that grew up in a
white neighborhood and you're also gay
and i'm like
this is gonna be hard like i gotta take
acting classes like this is gonna take
some work for sure you know and that's
what i was kind of thrown into i'm like
yo acting is [ __ ] hard
100 no it's so tough man like i
it's i think every time i get introduced
to a new opportunity i do truly realize
like how much
i'm not ready for it you know more than
that i'm ready for it
because we've been in entertainment you
know acting is a whole nother thing
though you know and
when you get tossed into those things
like you realize damn like there are
[ __ ] who are good at this
and he even like and and you got to
realize we talk about like
this podcast is brought to you by babble
my friends
that's japanese son and that's what i've
been learning
from babel bet you thought i was from
japan and if you didn't
well guess what give me a few more
months on babel and i'm about to have
this language down
on pat right now i speak korean and
english and i'm trying to add a third
language and pablo makes this process so
easy learning a new language
is so difficult but with this app it's
been pretty fun and it kind of teaches
you in a way that you would actually use
in the real world babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language
on the go unlike the infamous language
classes you took in high school
babel designs their courses with
practical real world conversations in
mind which by the way
is the stuff that you need to get around
when you travel and i travel
quite a bit i do travel and learning
language in this type of way is the way
to go plus babel speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and
accent which is super important so right
now with the purchase of a three month
babble subscription you'll get an
additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to battle.com and use promo code
gb
that's ba bbel.com code gb for an extra
three months
free babble language for life the
diversity in hollywood and all that
stuff and we
want you know uh representation with
asians and and black latino
all that you'll go into these improv
classes you'll go into the on set and
there are
crazy good white people at the [ __ ]
because they've been in it longer
you gotta understand that you gotta
understand that it's not like and i'm
not like
you know bigging up mad white people i'm
just being real like
dude you go into ucb class these white
people were like
goofy as [ __ ] like don't be down and get
goofy i think
culturally too in a lot of our cultures
like we haven't had that upbringing
where
we felt like we're allowed to be goofy
that that like yeah yeah
yeah yeah and goofy with it you know
what i'm saying especially
specifically i think in the asian
culture yeah and you'll see that when
you go into these ucb
classes and see like these white kids
who's signing up for the first time and
[ __ ]
that are willing to do uh act this way
or that you're a squirrel
yeah exactly and and you i think those
moments are something that a lot of
people
we don't talk about a lot it's like
there is like
they're kind of ahead in that way you
know what i'm saying there's mad
talented people of all races i'm just
saying
they're ahead and i think an upbringing
where a lot of that was maybe encouraged
but also in the industry too
where there's been decades ahead of us
in that well it's
you know i agree with that because it's
the same idea of
sometimes people don't understand like
the immigrant struggle when it comes to
an education right so
my thing is this people sometimes think
about wealth as just money
but there's also knowledge and
upbringing which is a big thing right so
when i was trying to apply for colleges
my parents didn't know how to apply for
scholarships my parents didn't know how
to even get into a college or even the
whole application process i had to
figure that out my own
right right and that's that knowledge
and upbringing that it's not actually a
financial gain
but that knowledge allows you to be
successful in the avenue that you're
going into right
and so if you have like for example like
because they have seen so many like
white people on screen and
acting as a viable option for that
culture yeah it's gonna be easier for
them to do
it they're going to be a little more
open right so that makes complete sense
and i do see that a lot too
you know even with like um like we're
starting to see we're
we're at the point that probably they
were 50 60 years ago
so now we got to play catch-up you know
100 i i feel
like that's why a lot of the asian
actors like
that are killing it on netflix have like
they were adopted by white parents
like that ass because and i'm not you
know there's nothing wrong with that i'm
just saying
i i there's there's a lot yeah and i i
like i was like damn why why is that and
i was like maybe they were encouraged
more i don't know
i don't know but i i was just trying to
put together a pattern there like
but i felt like maybe that could have
been a possibility you know they had
more parents that were like
down for them to full-on goal take them
to an audition or
get an agent when they were 10 years old
you know what i'm saying i mean i
started seeing differences in acting and
like so i did this
i played a small part in this uh indie
film with uh
uh matt mcgorry and uh lamorin morris
right yeah so i played like this
uh pervert telemarketer dude right but
just watching lamorne morris work
i was looking at him like oh [ __ ] he's
he's better like he's just better yeah
he's a beast the morning you know so
when they give him a line he has all
these different options and he's like
telling me
oh before i even go in i have i've
already thought about different line
options for everything that i'm saying
i was like yeah me too man yeah me too i
was
i was doing that too i was sleeping in
my room you know what this guy is
prepped and he's ready
so there's levels to this [ __ ] and this
is stuff that i wasn't privy to i
wouldn't even know that unless he told
me
right you know yeah which is kind of
nuts nah there's a lot of [ __ ] i i think
just i think we come from there's a
little bit of arrogance on our part
because we feel like we've already
come in and established our personality
i think we have a big perk too that a
lot of those artists don't it's because
we were able to just kind of we were
able to come in and just be
us you know what i'm saying a lot of
acting is like you go in
you audition for tons of [ __ ] that you
don't want to do you know what i mean
and that's something you're going to
have to do if you want to be an actor go
into mad auditions and
dude like memorizing [ __ ] and then going
into an audition and killing it like
that could take up
a good portion of your day you know what
i'm saying and
for somebody who's like pursuing other
things that's tough that's why like man
i respect the actors who like
just do that yeah yeah you know what i
mean like and what made you
start to go into acting i think for me
like i was a latchkey child probably
just like you growing up on television
and film like
i literally my whole personality is
based off of sitcoms from like the 90s
2000s you know what i'm saying and
comedy and
i love standup i'm like obsessed with
stand-ups yeah all that
and i think i just wanted to
do that like i want to create stuff but
honestly only in the last
five years i feel like i'm able to
create i've been able to really find my
voice
and storytelling skills like because i
knew who i was like oh this is me blah
blah but it's like i didn't know how to
package it
you know i only just recently knew how
to package i went to tons of auditions
i've been acting for a while now but
i haven't been booking [ __ ] you know so
my old thing is like
now i'm developing [ __ ] and i'm writing
you know and
shows that i want to be in i've realized
that's how i want to
break into the hollywood i don't think
it's going to be a with a role
that of a show that's super popular that
i necessarily didn't want to even be in
or cared about
well it's hard right because there was a
kid that asked me this in a college
uh i was asked to speak there and they
were asking me
do i feel or am i annoyed or irritated
that there's not a lot of like
rules for people like me and you right
and my response to it was like well i'm
not irritated or annoyed i'm
saying like even if they did try to
write my life they couldn't do it so
that's why we have a lot of shitty
asian american films because they're
writing from a perspective that they
don't know about
unless that's an asian person that went
through that you can't talk about like
specific nuance that we went through
right that's why you see a lot of these
korean adaptations of these films such
as old boy
one of the worst films i've ever seen
right right because they don't know what
it
is
bad about that yeah that was man i
believe they've done that with uh my
sassy girl one of the most popular
rom-coms right
right but there's cultural nuance that
isn't really picked up right yeah and
that's what happens in writings of
asian-american films when it's not from
a perspective that they know so i can't
even be mad at them for making a shitty
asian film because you don't know what
it's like
right so it's like i'd rather do your
route and say hey i'm going to create
something
it's coming from my and then you guys
can relate to it i think i think you
have to do that if you
if you truly want something rep
of your life represented you can't wait
for it man
you know because and you can't just just
expect it to happen from another asian
person either
because there's all these different
types of asians and you know i grew up
this it's been a renaissance for asian
uh american media
last five years or so but i haven't
necessarily haven't seen mad [ __ ] that i
can relate to besides a factor asian
yeah the fact that they're asian you
know what i'm saying so
to me that part is frustrating too
because the rest of the world thinks
like finally you got what you want
asians
yeah yeah yeah yeah but is it really
what i want i it's not necessarily
representative of my story
you know what i'm saying so well that's
why i got like super irritated when
people were asking me if i liked uh
crazy rich asians and i said no and
they're like well you should support it
anyway so i was like no i don't have to
do [ __ ] you suck my dick
how about that like at the end of the
day like i'll i bought tickets
right right i'll do it with my money but
you can't tell me to say tell me i have
to like it just because
yeah all that stuff gets so tricky right
because
in the heat of everything it is
important to support a movement because
it becomes bigger than just the movie
right yeah so which is why i
talked about this too because it's like
it's like
do you want to be super anti like siskel
and ebert with the [ __ ] film right
now
yeah yeah like not right now man maybe
when it hits dvd but you know what i'm
saying right because i you know i was
like that first house like but you know
what this is not the
that's probably not even the time for me
to bash
this movie yeah i'm saying i it wasn't
like i hate it or nothing it was just
like i
didn't feel like you know it's like
you can think about that right would you
support this like if you weren't asian
or if there wasn't a movement behind it
i don't know
like would i actually watch it and love
it you know yeah i mean for me too like
i did a video about it i said like i
bought tickets that's that's where my
money's gonna go like i'll let my money
talk
yeah but at the end of the day if you're
gonna ask me if somebody did if i liked
the film i would tell you no it was
it was i don't really like rom-coms as
much and that wasn't really a good one
but i will say this
i did that cast being all asian did do
something
for me i will say this like when i
watched it like opening scene you know
uh the the mom who comes with the kids
yeah yeah yeah she just like buys the
hotel like
yeah like i felt something you know i
thought something and like
i think that's the thing like i think we
got to like just
feel it feel it out in that sense too
like as a rom-com like i watch
i love rom-coms too you know what i mean
but it didn't necessarily do much for me
as a rom-com
but it did do something for me that the
whole cast was asian
there were like asian elements in the
thing
and maybe it also like it might have not
touched you directly because it is a
it's also
very chinese yeah you know what i mean
and well i just thought it was a [ __ ]
movie that's all
yeah that's that's always going to be my
basis for something because for example
not too long for that and then john
cho's searching came out right and i was
like yeah this shit's [ __ ] good
right right you know i think that
happens a lot too with um
really cultural movies that have like
cultural nuances in it like people
expect all asians to relate
like no chinese and koreans mad exactly
it's like
there's a lot of different things so um
those are elements to
obviously like we think about searching
um
that was a good thriller and then i saw
the the i saw a screening of minari
damn oh yeah that [ __ ] film is nuts
that [ __ ] was
you know what's amazing about uh that
movie i'm not gonna spoil it for people
because obviously it hasn't come out yet
but it's
it really was like didn't you feel like
damn i never thought a movie like this
would ever come out
well because the premise of it sounds
like a comedy if you let me not even
think about it i didn't think does it
look like a comment in the trailer well
if you guys don't know like the premise
of it it's very
here's like the way it was described to
me before i saw it right yeah it's this
[ __ ]
korean dude that thinks it's a good idea
to grow a korean crop in america
so i started crack i was like yo this is
hilarious
the premise sounds so [ __ ] stupid
right it's like i have a good idea i'm a
girl
it's a plant nobody eat you know and i'm
like come on man like
i will say i will say that was an
ambitious project for an immigrant
that was a very ambitious because i like
i actually i don't want to go into
details because there's actually
where he's coming from and all this
stuff but it's
very ambitious right now i heard the the
the i started dying laughing i'm like
yo this guy's a [ __ ] jackass like
what a terrible terrible move
and you bring your whole family over for
the [ __ ] you [ __ ] and i saw this film
i'm like this is the
one of the best [ __ ] films i've seen
it's so good you know what here's the
thing about that i
i really did respect that element too
because i will say i think coming to
this country
for a lot of immigrants like taking a
chance like that
because coming to the country is already
taking a chance yeah doing that
is like what are you doing yeah but but
it's it's risky for immigrants to take a
complete
different chance than like work for like
a com like try to work at like under
somebody or something you know what i
mean
so that was a very ambitious thing like
my dad came and like worked for some
dude
yeah you know what i'm saying like he
went to the the [ __ ] middle of
nowhere
to grow a crop that no nobody eats butt
korean people
i i really did enjoy it it was a man
it's a korean american film
yeah like i never thought that was gonna
happen like
it's so good i really was like you know
it's like whether you enjoy it or not if
you're a korean
korean-american you're going to be like
damn i never thought there would be an
a24 film
in america that has all this [ __ ] the
way i grew up and things like that and
it's so good too because you're just
going to relate to it on a human level
so it's
the film is pretty amazing i mean have
you ever thought about doing a story
because wait hold on did you
were you born in argentina i was i was i
was born in argentina the crazy story
with me is like my mom
smuggled me and my sister in through the
mexican border
with coyotes what the [ __ ] are you
talking about right now i was three
years old my mom my sister my younger
sister was
one and she brought us into the mexican
border illegally
i didn't become a citizen until like
seven years ago
like they should have built a wall you
know one of those one of those
[ __ ] dude
i barely made the gun barely made the
cut
uh so the story is like
we didn't have any ways to get in here
like legally
you know what i'm saying yeah so my mom
uh got like
they so my my dad came in here first
solo and like got a job and was sending
us money
like to argentina for like uh a year to
like a year or two before like sending
my mom is setting up a way for her to
like get through this thing i don't know
the full details but
they hired a kite like the coyotes and
it was like like a two-day
three-day thing or something and she
tells me these stories like it was mad
scary one night because like she was
like holding us close
and one of the dudes was like super sus
like peeking in there like a flashlight
and [ __ ]
making sure like everyone's cool but she
was really scared that she might get
raped or something like that
god damn but um yeah that's just wild
um buenos aires through mexico and then
k-town pretty much
what the [ __ ] so what was your mom's
like first job then when she got here
um i mean my dad was just working really
okay
that's a lot of meat now i mean you know
but uh i come from like the downtown
wholesale kind of
koreans yeah yeah yeah yeah like not
like clothing and [ __ ] but my dad was
got into like toys and [ __ ] like that so
that didn't do well at all
it wasn't like forever 21 billion that's
another [ __ ] me naughty story dude
to sell toys i was like toys r us is
down the street
like what are you thinking man yeah i
don't know so like
you see my parents and my my korean
like upbringing is interesting because
my parents really made bad
choices like you know they didn't buy
any property or anything
you know and even the wholesale business
that my dad came up in like
he's he's like still doing that and it's
been struggling like
he just recently like he was about to
completely shut it down
and then it started doing well because
he started slanging masks
and he was like this [ __ ] is booming and
he literally
saved his business through slinging
masks that's crazy
and then i checked him with two months
he's like yeah dude i finally was able
to pay my debts off
i called him back like two weeks ago
he's like yeah he's doing [ __ ] again
[Laughter]
everyone got their masks and like it's
just doing bad again it's like sudden
i'm in debt
it's like wait wow how did this happen
but but like i when i was like 12 my
parents split up you know like
a lot like a lot of korean uh you know
parents domestic violence
you know my dad was alcoholic you know
all that stuff they split up when i was
like 12 13 years old
and um you know like did you leave with
your mom
and your dad was just or did you guys
split time
so they split up when i was like 12 13
and i was
it was all like mixed because they never
got a divorce they just been separated
for that long
that's hilarious yeah they never got a
divorce like and and they never
run into each other ever like they
haven't seen each other in like decades
what in the [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's hilarious it's it's
weird it's a very k-town
like like i'm very k-town that way like
that is the most korean
town thing i've ever heard in my life
yeah so
they hate each other pretty much you
know what i'm saying and like
um but there was a thanksgiving like two
years ago where
me and my sister talked to both of them
like it's like yo let's just all try to
like meet up y'all i haven't seen each
other in like 15 years or something
20 years met up for like cha chang i got
a chatting man spot in k-town
really and sat down it was chill
it was cool and then since 10 days i'm
seeing each other they're like i filled
my quota yeah
i'm done with this [ __ ] but it's i feel
like that's the thing like that's why i
want to tell my story because i feel
like i represent a very very like
like a trailer trash version of koreans
you know what i mean like there's a lot
of korean kids that grow up this way in
k-town
you know that don't yeah people don't
know what k-town koreans are like it's
very because i didn't know i grew up in
sacramento so when i came here it was
just it was [ __ ] aladdin a whole new
world i'm like yo what the [ __ ] are with
these korean people here dude you guys
are [ __ ] weird right
right right you [ __ ] trash bags like
i'm like
these [ __ ] you know let me tell you
the smell like cigarette butts man
why do you guys smell like hot dog water
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
[ __ ]
dog the the fun there's so many weird
k-town stories just because i lived
there for six seven years
i wanted to know what this culture was
about right even something as funny as
this
like i remember coming to k-town and i
talked i was talking to this girl
and she had a thick ass [ __ ] korean
accent right i was like oh when did you
come to the stage she goes
uh i was born here i'm like you were
born here
what the [ __ ] is with your english there
is a k-town
cadence if you will there's a k-town
cadence um
i would say it's slightly it's like bob
influenced
and latino influence yeah
you know what i mean you've mastered
that little accent
i've done it too and the funny thing is
i don't really have it and i'm from cape
town my whole life and that's
that's the thing it's like i grew up
very k-town with my family and stuff but
the way
i when i was a kid growing up i got into
so many different like
i was hanging out with little artsy kids
and underground hip-hop shows
but i'm very k-town that's why i like i
feel like when i want to tell the story
because i'm able to have like an outside
perspective
to my own world you know what i'm saying
like and a lot of the kids there
like they're in it in it you know and
and it's like i've always that's why i i
empathize with so many different
communities where like
people are part of those communities and
that that can't really defend themselves
like verbally in these bigger
conversations
or or just you know this podcast is
brought to you by
june b matcha do you hate the jitters
and crash that coffee gives you well
say no more my friends because hundreds
of thousands of people are drinking jun
b matcha not only for the health
benefits
but for the caffeine boost that lasts
without the crash of coffee you can mix
it
have it hot ice cold or try it with your
favorite juices and have
fun with it remember not all matcha is
created the same and junebe has the
highest quality matcha you can find
straight from a farm in japan
hand-picked and curated to get you the
best
quality there is no competition to get
10 off your first order of tins and
packets go to
junebeshop.com that's j-u-n-b-i
shop.com and enter codegeniusbrain to
get 10
off your first order that's
j-u-n-b-i-shop.com
code geniusbrain
growing up i was just like part of
something and you felt it and you part
of it
now like gotta break down what that
relationship means what that
friendship is how do you put it into
words i know i can't
i you know it's funny because i come
from like making music and
rapping and stuff and it's so tough like
i never thought
i remember the first time i was ever
approached about
these things i didn't know how to answer
it you know i did like
i started rapping when i was 14 years
old i remember when i was 19 i did a
college show and in a panel afterwards
and some college kid is like asking me
about cultural appropriation
i looked over to my friend i was like i
was like yeah
exactly that's what you say yeah exactly
what but and i looked
i looked mad stupid i didn't know what
it meant and and i've learned i was like
oh [ __ ] like
i didn't know people would look at me
that i'm doing this
thing and i was like i didn't feel like
i wasn't i was doing it but then i also
understood like how it might look from
the outside perspective right
so i really looked at it but it's so
difficult like i wasn't ready for these
things and i think
nowadays it's like we all have to look
look at
all our actions but it kind of does take
away
the the fun funniness of participating
in something and really just being in
that culture
because when you're in it it don't feel
like anything else it feels like a
like a well because now universal things
we don't have small communities now
we have the internet right so everybody
feels like they have a say
in everybody else's community even
though they haven't experienced or been
a part of it
which is always a little weird for me
right so when they when
when kids ask about these topics and we
talked about this before
i genuinely believe there's a lot of
great people who really want to learn
but there's this other small subset of
people who just want to pat on their
back for being woke
and they are kind of causing a lot more
hate and anger than they are bringing up
conversation
right so for example there was a kid
that wrote in my comment
about me not supporting i've never
supported asian people at all
and i literally wrote i was like dude
who the [ __ ] are you talking to right
now you know what i mean
it's like you got to be very careful
about who you're [ __ ] approaching
right now like you
you wrote this comment because you saw
my profile once you saw the following
but you didn't know who i am and who i'm
about and what i told this kid was like
it's cool for you to say that because
there's people like me and a bunch of
other people in this space that
we had to take shots for you to even
stand up the way you're doing right now
right so be quiet
sit down for a second like you don't
have the ability to go ahead and even
talk like this in this space
quite yet yeah well let me ask you this
like how
you you enjoy replying to those kind of
comments
right especially when i take a [ __ ]
that's like my most favorite so is it
like
literally i cause you know it's gonna be
exhausting you know you don't have to do
it
but like what makes you want to reply
only when i'm pooping
like i should show you it's it's
literally a thing that when i when i
poop
is when i do it like an extracurricular
pooping activity
exactly replying to trolls so i don't i
don't get emotional anymore
okay like so you're not you're not it's
not affecting you when you do reply no
no because usually when i reply it's
affecting me it used to
you know i'd like quite a few years back
it used to the last time
something really pissed me off was um
that one girl that i mentioned on your
podcast where she was saying i was i was
a misogynist and a sexist
you know that was a funny thing there
was a there was a homegirl a k-town girl
uh one of my home girls who got
approached by david in one of the videos
and she was really offended because
david kind of roasted her
and she hit me uh and i i recognized her
and this turned into a whole thing
online where you guys are going back and
forth well i wasn't even
i was listen she's she's your friend
right i mean she's yeah she's like a
home like acquaintance she's she's an
acquaintance homegirl right
the the the issue that i had with it was
people like her who weaponized an actual
issue
just so she could look good and that's
why i that's why i got upset right it
was like
because what she specifically wrote was
women are you going to let this
misogynist talk about all of us all of
us like this i was like oh i wasn't
talking about oh well i'll talk about
you
you know right right the the joke of the
thing was
i'm david soh i'm not attractive i don't
get girls so i'm just making up an
excuse
of this per because she looks like a
perfectly normal girl right so that's
why that joke is so stupid right if she
looked like
a loose woman which was the joke then it
wouldn't be funny
it's just me making a commentary about
how a woman looks
the joke is that i'm a slob and girls
don't like me right but all she heard
was the word right and everybody got it
in the comments and because she made
that comment
what happened was that she got upset and
all the comments started roasting her
because they thought she was being dumb
and so i was like and the one thing is i
apologize to that i actually had asked
my mom i'm like
what did i do and she goes well she
wasn't a participant in the joke and you
made a joke about her and i'm like
oh okay i get that you know and i was
like hey my bad this one and i literally
told her
this is what my mom said and so i'm
going to apologize to you because i was
making a joke and you weren't you
weren't a participant in it
and so if you're offended my bad i think
the thing about it is it's like
it's very easy for you to completely
overpower somebody verbally like that's
what you do
yeah you know what i'm saying so that
could be very overwhelming for someone
who's not ready for that yeah you know
what i'm saying but i will say this for
anybody who's out there like listening
who
wants to know how to handle these things
i i there's
nothing to handle like that's always
going to be there yeah
trolling is always going to be their
hater comments are always going to be
there
i don't think we need to think about it
as like so deep and you know
uh because honestly those people who are
doing that
say they might be miserable they're
probably miserable
in life and honestly that's the one perk
they have
yeah the one perk is talking [ __ ] online
so they are allowed to do that that is
the one thing they are allowed to do if
they can't do anything else to be honest
yeah and you know after that too i'm
like when i got disappointed in myself
because i was like
i don't know her but in my mind i'm like
this person is beneath me why am i
why am i getting worked up about right
and then you know
there's such a funny backstory to this
too because
there was there was two actually two
girls that were there right it was her
and somebody who i thought was her
friend or whatever what not
and so we actually apologized we're like
hey like ah we
we didn't that's a very rare thing a
davidson apology yeah very rare thing i
have to like look deep if i don't feel
like i did anything wrong i'm gonna
apologize
right but then you know my mom spoke to
me about like hey like you can make
jokes but they got to be a part know
that they're a part of the joke
what are these okay i'm actually curious
about you and your mom's
dynamic because this is funny like
because i
i know like everybody knows your
personality you're going on people
and you destroy these [ __ ] like
what is the conversation with your mom
does she like
check you sometimes to calm down or like
what is it like it's always to come
i talk to my mom probably like three or
four times a week
so she's she's one of those parents who
don't really lecture me anymore
like she just wants to talk and have fun
so a lot of the time she's like my voice
of reasoning even though she's a [ __ ]
psychopath
but she's a psychopath in her own realm
but she could look from an outside
perspective and see my behavior because
she's seen me since i was in diapers
so she knows when i'm being unreasonable
so i have to ask her like hey what the
[ __ ] am i doing wrong again yeah
you know yeah cause i'm i'm clearly
doing something wrong cause i'm angry
why am i angry about this
she's like you're angry because you you
responded like a dumb ass she like gets
through you yeah like she really
she's one of the few people that like
gets through you and makes you reason
with yourself so what she was saying was
like you're not angry
you're angry at yourself you're angry
because you let this person bother you
and they're beneath you
right and and then you hurt this
person's feelings and now you're
embarrassed and i'm like
oh maybe that's what it is right and i
was like gosh she didn't she didn't
deserve to get her feelings hurt even
though that's not the intention
the outcome was that she was hurt
because she's not smart enough to
understand the joke
that's how i rationalize it right right
so the funny backstory behind that was
that
um we apologized to uh both of them one
of the girls and i guess like uh
tim was like hey like if you want like
we could squash this buy you a meal or
whatever and he offered it to the other
girl but not
your friend who got mad and so she got
so mad she's not even friend with the
other girl now
oh wow yeah talk about toxic [ __ ]
god bless you and i hope you're having a
lovely day and i hope one day we can
meet each other and pray but that's but
when
when that happened i was like it
actually felt like vindication for me i
was like oh my mom was right
she's not trying to be reasonable she
literally cut out her friend because she
didn't get offered a meal so she's not
even talking to that girl anymore and
i'm like
now i understand how dumb i am because i
got sucked into the stupid [ __ ]
right you know so i had to be like this
is why my mom is there to tell me i'm
stupid because she knows how dumb i am
sometimes yeah
yeah what are you doing this is so
stupid and i've wasted a whole day on
this
you know a whole day i'll never get back
oh man you had a
your 2020 was interesting because you
you called out
a significant amount an amount of people
and after like uh
you know the first and second like after
the second video i was like you know
what like
i'm really enjoying me kind of
at first i was like i think he's going a
little like too much you know what i'm
saying
and then i was like after the second i
was like okay i'm starting to see like
what this is and why this might be
needed
almost you know what i'm saying because
there's something powerful about like
you know when you're roasting like your
own people
yeah and i think that's we don't talk
about that a lot because we went through
so much
of the phase where support support
support
anything asian you're down with the
asians and all that but there's power in
that where you got to call out your own
community right because like
for me maybe it's because i always had a
huge problem with
like i unders that word appropriation is
always a little weird for me right
but i've always had an issue with
and people may or disagree with this i
have a lot of issues with korean artists
who didn't grow up in this culture
taking from a culture and they don't
want to give back like it's always
infuriating from like korean korean
korean yeah yeah chinese people korean
people asian people whatever right right
and then when they make insensitive
jokes
about some real [ __ ] that's happening in
this country
yeah the culture that they've stolen
from and if you want to take whatever
you're you're in that cut you're in a
different country that's fine but
there's people literally being murdered
and killed out here
right right you should know better
you're from here
as a human being yeah yeah you know as a
human being you shouldn't do that [ __ ]
and so you know there are still people
now that are still getting flame from
the videos that i made that girl
was one that you went in i mean wait
that was two
which was uh the rapper and then i'm not
even saying the names just the girl
the korean american girl and then the
rapper girl yeah those are totally
deserved a hundred percent and i think
that's why i enjoyed it really
a lot but man that that girl was like
doubling down on her [ __ ] which was even
making it
frustrating like i wanted you to go in
for a second round there was like two or
three i saw it
[Laughter]
somebody sent me her stuff and then
there's a lot of people who know her
this world's very small
right and they're like she's kind of
like weird like she's crazy
and so i'm like now i'm just bullying a
a mentally disturbed person
so i i decided to stop i was like she's
actually mentally
right right so now like being a bully
but she might full on just be like
qa non mega maybe dude you know
i hope she catches coven i hope it
already happened she just
i feel like she would be like you know
marching with the anti oh for sure dude
like you know she's in ralph's
you know and
you know it's weird with the uh with the
rapper i don't even know his name um
but he dm me this whole thing like
apologizing or whatever i was like don't
say sorry to me
like you ain't got to say like for me
too it's like
i the what he said was so
personally offensive you know i mean it
was kind of nuts
it's like bro you could have just not
said anything you could have just
changed
that's the thing and that's one thing i
always say like you can
you know be on this i don't give a [ __ ]
i drop out of school and all this [ __ ]
but if you're not educated and you're in
a situation like that
you can keep digging yourself in a hole
it's like that girl with the daddy hat
yeah that girl was just stupid you know
what i'm saying and you just
you went on an interview made it two
times worse
and then they released the uncut version
like
the director's cut of the video yeah and
then she went for three rounds of that
[ __ ] like
and and i feel like that's the part like
where you don't realize you can be like
throwing your middle fingers up i don't
go [ __ ] this this for a long time
until you get to a situation where
someone's gonna roast you in your
language
yeah and then you're not gonna be able
to
respond or rebuttal and that's why
that's when the education is important
you know what i'm saying like you got to
have to at least know how to
back up your [ __ ] like even if it's like
a complete opposite belief you better
sound kind of smart saying that
100 and like for me too i'm not like
huge into like
cancel culture either like i'm not
trying to cancel these people
but if who better than somebody who's a
part of the same culture to tell you to
shut the [ __ ] up
right like people always say police your
own right and that's really what i was
doing it's like oh you're a part of my
community and they
executed themselves you didn't like put
them in timeout
you're like yeah and it's weird too like
i stopped doing those videos because
it started making me into an angry
person yeah because like i i
like because i didn't even search for
this [ __ ] people kept sending it to me
yeah and i started getting like every
day waking up pissed off
and i'm like i can't do this anymore
your videos is like i i
will say when i see you doing i'm like
damn like it's a
it's i feel like it would be very
stressful for you
you know like when i watch him i'm like
i think
the people feel the same way i do like
we're like part of us like bro i think
you're kind of doing overdoing it
but you feel good too watching it you
know what i'm saying
and because you know that person
probably deserves it but
you really going on them and destroy
them and the thing
the bigger thing for me is like damn
damn i can't do it you know what i'm
saying like
i mean i could i'm just saying like it
would invite so much stress i feel like
you guys the stress level is really high
and like the weird thing is people would
always ask like how long did it take you
to write that i'm like
i didn't write that [ __ ] i just stared
into a [ __ ] camera and i was
screaming like a maniac
right and i'm like that's good and i
just uploaded it that's all that it was
that's intense bro
so i have to be actually upset and care
about something enough to say that you
know
yeah so before when it was like vlogs i
would sit there and i would write points
out and i'm like okay let's see what i
can do with it and
now it's just like i think it's a lesson
though i mean even
it looks really harsh but the truth is
like look like
that girl was so terrible we don't even
remember her [ __ ] name anymore you
know what i'm saying like the thing is
people will forget about it but at least
that's the lesson they learned
for whatever long it was a month or two
months or whatever
you know and i feel like those lessons
all should be learned i i don't believe
that any
like they're gonna be canceled forever
there's no
no you know cancel means like you're
done done you know what i mean and
there's mad people who we think are just
get canceled like nah like
some [ __ ] happens where they'll be able
to come back but i think
initially if some [ __ ] [ __ ] up happens
to them at the moment like
a lot of times it is deserved you know
what i'm saying and but then i don't
i think people try to fight the cancer
culture because they think
you're completely canceling them but i
don't believe in it i don't think that
happens really
for me it's like it's i wanted to make
an example out of these people
so the next time there's another korean
rapper or musician or whatever that
thinks that it's okay
to go ahead and just make fun of a
culture while they're being killed
it's like you're gonna think twice
that's the audacity right there like
that like making hip-hop music and
criticizing black lives matter it's like
it doesn't mean wow
like it's unbelievable almost yeah it's
like i'm like for me it's like
just just look the boogeyman is going to
come for you like i'm going to come for
you like it's going to happen i think
that's the part about
and that is the part that i really do
understand why people get mad about
appropriation yeah and that gives them
an excuse to really really be mad about
and i completely empathize and
understands that i
understand that when they when it has
become
crazy profitable uh culture
all around the world nobody even knows
the history of how hip-hop started to
most of these
dudes who make way more money than me
pretty much yeah i've been in the game
i've done research on hip hop like you
know i got a picture with cool hurricane
[ __ ] when i was eight like
all this stuff you know but it's like
you have kids all over the world and i
get it like
these [ __ ] you know are making
so much [ __ ] money off of everything
the branding of it
you know but but it's a tricky thing
because
people they do they do uh
come up in the culture rapping the same
way most kids do
like a community of people who are in
hip-hop making music yeah that's why
those people is like it's hard to
say or think anything about you know
that's why life for me was more of these
people who are in the peripheral that
are just taking and taking and taking
and but they don't want to partake in
the uplifting of a culture that allows
you to have a paycheck
you know and how i say that too if i
want if i you know just to
just korean people in general right
because i'm korean that's like um
somebody taking lightly of the um
of japan taking over our country and our
comfort women right and somebody kind of
just made jokes about that
and then we could look at them and say
like what's the problem it happened in
the past like
why are you so still pissed about it
yeah yeah like we're we're being very
dismissive of of a country's history
you know so if you could put the you
know the shoe on you on the other foot
you should be able
to do that for anything that you're
doing right now yeah and so like you
know that was like a quick stint i
haven't really done it since
it was raising my [ __ ] blood pressure
well i think that was
yeah i mean it was one of those things
that even if
when you were going harsh on them people
wanted you to do it because they were
so shitty in like the way they were
coming at it it's like even if you're
the rapper
like who have never who has never been
into that and just
are in hip-hop like profiting off of
making mad money don't know
[ __ ] that was probably your one chance
to even look like you gave a [ __ ] i know
he went the opposite way on that yeah so
i mean it was something that's very easy
for me to be vocal about because like
for me
i grew up in a community was majority
asian and black people
you know my parents owned a black beauty
supply store i went i went to a black
church for
uh half my life right so it was it was
it's my best friend is black so it's
like this is something that's very near
and dear to me so it felt like i
almost felt personal like you know what
i mean i didn't want to pat on the back
for i don't want any of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] i didn't even think it was like
that many people were going to see it
you know i think that was your service
you know everybody was doing something
during that drive
that was your thing you had to roast
these dudes that's that's what it was
because the first thing was the the
video that did well was um the time in
place video like yeah this is just
common sense to me you know that was
that was very
and you explained it very well because
it's that's that's a very simple
time and place makes sense that's all i
wanted you know
and uh that was the weird part too where
i i didn't realize sometimes the stuff
that i think is common sense isn't
common sense to everybody else
so i was like oh [ __ ] like i didn't know
that this was gonna blow somebody's
[ __ ] mind
because they're tagging other people
because they couldn't say what i was
saying
they're like okay i'm not gonna i'm just
gonna tag them like hey you watch this
because this is what i was trying to
tell you
you know by the way um
it's funny because today is martin
luther king day
but last night i watched uh the tiger
woods documentary
and um have you seen this no i haven't
seen it oh bro
it is off the chain like so good bro so
good
but like he's like amazing tiger woods
first of all amazing
probably like uh like older asian dude's
favorite black dude yeah
like no doubt about that you know what
i'm saying like my dad loved tiger woods
more than me bro 100
like a dead ass i just looked at you
like what the [ __ ] is this yeah i was
like dad can we go play catch it's like
shut up tiger's playing
but uh yeah so watching the documentary
and
he just you know he was on a spree of
the mistresses 14 like
white women they all look like karen's
from the videos from the past year
doc he was like i was like out of all
the women he could have bagged yeah they
were some of the
most basic ugliest women i've ever seen
in my life what's going on with him
because he has a type you know and but
the thing is like bro
that's he could do if he wants to smash
14 karen's like that's you
you know it's tiger it's tiger yeah but
here's the thing i i felt like
the biggest takeaway from that is like
america is just so mean
bro like to to like
looking at this documentary on his life
all this great stuff that
eclipses this like scandal you know what
i mean
like he went out with he was he was
cheating on his wife with 14
uh girls you know what i'm saying 14
women
and like that was like half of the
documentary
you know oh really he's won like 78
tournaments yeah
you know and and then the half of the
[ __ ] thing is the scandal and i'm
like bro that's how [ __ ] up we are
and even how that got exposed was this
national enquirer reporter was
following him around like town looking
for something
looking for every little thing and i was
just thinking about how [ __ ] up we
look at this right like damn
like even i see the tweets after this
documentary i look at i looked i looked
up tiger like the key word and being
seeing what people are saying like man
tiger woods is wild
i'm like wild he's a professional
athlete yeah cheating on his wife of 14
that's pretty average
that's that's mad happening yeah it's
like that's swagless
you know what i'm saying but i was like
damn like just looking at that whole
thing in hindsight and how we
sensationalize all that just felt really
[ __ ] up you know
that's why everybody has to understand
too it's like the only difference
between a celebrity
being a piece of [ __ ] and you being a
piece of [ __ ] is that they're under a
microscope
you're not yeah you're arguably just as
worse and you have probably done way
worse things but it's easy for you to go
pick on people because they're
all their [ __ ] is out there they're
under a microscope and the funny thing
is is sometimes with these celebrities
they never chose to be idolized you made
them into
this figure of like morality when they
never were that person in the first
place they were pieces of [ __ ] i even
say it's about old people like being
nice to some of these old people why
they were probably a [ __ ] rapist when
they're young i don't know who the [ __ ]
this guy is
he's an [ __ ] to me now so he's still
an [ __ ] we really do look at uh
celebrities as gods though yeah that's a
perfect example and
i can see why like if you've seen tiger
played i'm making hole-in-ones and [ __ ]
i'm like how do you do that
like you really it really feels god-like
when you see
crazy athletes do incredible things yeah
like i really felt like that was like
this is magic like
have you ever gotten uh like stunned
when you met a celebrity
stunned like oh [ __ ] i'm actually
talking to this
i will say this i i don't get yeah i
think i get excited
and like even if i don't admit it like
i'm like talking extra like yeah
like trying to talk to them more you
know so i can tell that i get caught up
in that
you know and and it's because i did grow
up so
into hollywood and entertainment like i
grew up really
looking up to celebrities because i grew
up on television and film you know i'm
saying like
now uh i'm older you know like
i know how things are because i've
experienced it first hand to
being like having fans having a
following being so
you know a semi celebrity in that way
and dealing with that and dealing with
losing relevance getting hot again yeah
so i know how that feels you know um
but like i don't know if i've met that
one person that made me like
really good i feel like it maybe would
that be though
obama maybe obama that's a curveball i
did not expect that [ __ ] at all
why obama do out of all the people what
the random there's
those things that make me excited like
okay like i meant
that okay well because i i don't know
like
something about him seems like very like
he's not like a celebrity too he's just
like so iconic in a way i don't know why
yeah
you didn't expect that i said obama i'm
like there's a thing that made me feel
really good like i met method man
and he knew about me and he knew my it
was like quoting my battle lines and
[ __ ] yeah
that felt [ __ ] good but that i played
in the beginning i was like oh man
respect
i went away i was like yeah yeah i was
giddy as [ __ ]
yeah um uh no i think it's also maybe
the l.a effect of being in l.a and
seeing celebrities yeah yeah yeah
you go to the grove and some
[ __ ] there you know yeah yeah
that's true
i feel like if i met well originally it
was bill cosby deal i found out he was a
rapist oh my god
wait are you were you a bill cosby fan
as a
uh like actor his show is influenced my
whole life
really like the cosby show i did not
grow up on the cosby i grew up on the
clock because i think it was a little
bit before my time but
it is i saw all the reruns that's yeah
you watched like nick at night or some
[ __ ]
well it was all public television so
whatever was on public television i
watched so
whether it was fresh prince of bel-air
but the cosby show is my favorite uh
sitcom of all time even above
the fresh prince because like he molded
his
not the one in jail the guy on the tv
show molded my
idea of number one like even i think
how i view black culture right you know
what i mean because i watched that show
so religiously
it actually even molded the type of
women woman that i wanted in my life
like a claire huxtable a woman who got
her [ __ ] done didn't need
uh heathcliff to pay for her [ __ ]
because she was a partner in a law firm
you know this is the type of stuff that
i grew
and they're the very first episode is
one of the funniest [ __ ] things that
you'll see in sitcom because
they didn't play sitcom tropes yeah they
just did some real [ __ ] which was cosby
stand-up
so he would it was the part where theo
comes in and he just his
shit's all [ __ ] up he's [ __ ] up to
school and he goes dad why can't you
just love me for who i
am and you're expecting that violin to
happen yeah and he looks at him he goes
theo
that's the dumbest thing i've ever heard
in my life clean your [ __ ]
on the way he talked um his like his
dialogue parts on that show
it felt very unscripted yeah you know
what i'm saying like he it just felt
like
him doing his one-liners as bill cosby
the stand-up
exactly and i thought and i thought
another person who had that kind of same
vibe is like someone like
like jerry seinfeld or something you
know he just does this kind of stand-up
exactly so these likes that's why like
the cosby show if i
now if i met him i'd be so disappointed
he wouldn't be able to see me he's blind
but like he i would have been super
disappointed i heard somebody threw a
jello pudding at him
in jail too i thought that was [ __ ]
hilarious but i think that person or
will smith if i met will smith i'd
probably [ __ ] be like oh [ __ ]
i will say i think now nowadays
i mean maybe i'm wrong but i'm hoping
people are more
conscious as they're climbing up this
journey of fame
because you have to be more careful
right these guys during that time
that were doing this they were living
like rock stars with no consequences
now there's tons of consequences like i
mean
there's there should have been way more
already you know but right now it's like
there's so much conversation around
so it makes me wonder if like young
artists
are acting accordingly as they climb up
this journey
i guess there's already kind of natural
restrictions
especially with like covens or just stop
sharing your [ __ ] on your stories you
[ __ ] dumbasses like what's wrong with
you man
right people can't help it dude bill
cosby here's a story that i heard from
somebody else
um this is during the time that he heard
from another comic
that had a very specific hairstylist
that used to do all these like shows for
comics so she's been around for a while
and she told him this story while she
was doing his makeup
and this is during the the cosby
controversy and what she told him was
like
i know he did that [ __ ] for a fact like
i know he's like what do you mean
she was like well when i was a young
makeup artist and i was doing his makeup
this man looked at me directly in my
eyes and he grabbed my breast
like like talon clawed grabbed it and
said
there's nothing you can do about it
right and he just went right back and i
had to go right back to doing his makeup
and he just kind of laughed about it
that's the type of man he was that's how
much power these fools had that's crazy
because like comedians when they were
huge apparently from what he was telling
me obviously i don't know
i wasn't even born i was super young he
was like these guys were living like
rock stars and they were gods they had
the key to these huge network television
shows
they were making money for networks they
were making money for comedy clubs
wherever they went
they were money machines so nobody could
say anything to them and there wasn't
the internet to call them out
so if they wanted to [ __ ] somebody do
whatever they want people just let them
do it and everybody was just complicit
allowing it to happen
that's the thing if you i mean honestly
you should not like nowadays you
shouldn't just uh wake up
and thank god you're able to wake up
another day
you should wake up and think that you're
not trending
like for real like wake up okay
like step one thank you lord i'm awake
yeah
go on twitter check the trend that
you're not trending
now i'm ready to start my day god bless
well there's a good thing like for me i
put all my [ __ ] dirty laundry out
it's like this is who i am even with
like i mean you don't you're not you're
not that problematic really
yeah i'm not a [ __ ] bag so it's like
yeah what are you guys gonna say like i
remember one time somebody's
there was like this little thread
talking about you know i was like well
david uses the n-word or whatever what
not right i was like i already addressed
that i used to use it when i was younger
i already addressed it you can't roast
me about stuff that i've already
acknowledged
like it's already there i have like 17
episodes about it
you know and the good thing because i do
that and i'm not trying to hide anything
and here's the thing the reason that
kids
uh less asian kids are are using it and
actually addressing it
is because [ __ ] used to use it
and are addressing it themselves
that's why there's more [ __ ]
like y'all being able to talk about it
yeah i'm saying
but yeah man it's a interesting time i
feel
just blessed man i feel like i am an
older person in
in the game and i'm not i'm not i'm not
super old but like i started
killed at all yeah but i started really
young and like
if you're comparing it to like the the
generation of now because i'm in youth
culture
i think a lot a lot of us are we're in
youth culture of entertainment
you know um and when you're in youth
culture
like we're part of a section that's not
necessarily really entapped with the
youth though like we're not living as
the youth
yeah yeah yeah that are like following
these things so i got an air filter i
just bought today
i got these leather seats yeah like
we're just not part of the youth
that that's the truth you know what i'm
saying like you couldn't be into like
young [ __ ] but you're not on you know in
school with seeing around the crowd and
if you are that's us but you know
if you are then you're kelly is what
yeah
but i feel like very blessed to even
have a platform and
have been able to make it this far in in
an environment where
anything can get you in trouble yeah
anything that you say
um can get you canceled quote unquote or
whatnot
so every day i am blessed and i feel
like i want to balance out what i want
to say
and speak freely but also just be smart
about it be smart and also listen to
people too
because that is important like i can
fight it all day you know
you can too we can fight it all day but
is it really going to be
helpful like are we is it or are we just
going in circles with a comment
i like getting old dude like i i never
appreciated it so much until like
i when i when i first hit like 30 right
yeah and
i started realizing i actually had a lot
more to talk about than when i was
younger when i was younger
i had to pretend like i knew what i was
talking about 100 percent i gotta agree
with you
i don't like much on that i'm like oh
[ __ ] i know things
you know there was a moment where i'm
like i actually can speak with
confidence because i
lived it now yeah now i don't have to
say stuff out of speculation
and so when i remember there was this
kid in this college he was like trying
to roast me like yeah
they always think that they could do it
right and so this kid was like oh how
does it feel like to be like the one old
person in like a group of young people
and i looked at this kid i was like
how much money you have in your bank
account right yeah i was like why the
[ __ ] would i be you
i was like you suck i was like you don't
know what you want
you're watching me because you're trying
to figure out what you're what you want
to do so why the [ __ ] would i want to be
you
you know people are laughing and i'm
like don't do the roast game thing here
dude
be gone i could do this for hours if
you'd like but what i was just basically
saying is like we're holding on to youth
as if it's something that's
so precious you know knowledge is
precious time is precious i agree with
that
but as you get older like these
experiences i can't have unless i aged
people could have told me the same
knowledge when i was younger and it
never would have went through
but because i went through it i
understand now i realize
how much i don't know now because i
spent so much time pretending i knew
[ __ ]
yeah you ever find yourself doing that
like you're like first it's like wait a
minute
i have all these videos about these
things i talked about how come i don't
know it
because i was pretending that i knew it
you know what i'm saying yeah like even
something small like this
right like i had this idea of what like
even relationships you guys
young people will always find this out
we have an idea of what we think a
healthy relationship is
because we idolize these other people
that we have maybe we even do it with
our parents
but then you start to realize how [ __ ]
up everybody is and then
it's like it's it's this thing that
everybody's still learning to do as they
grow together
right because i thought when i was
younger when you're older
like you had the answers for what makes
a healthy relationship then i find out
that people that i thought were the
healthiest are the most [ __ ] up
and they're just working through their
problems all the time but when i was a
kid
i was so definite in giving people
relationship advice about [ __ ] that i
didn't even know about
right it's like when you're in a
relationship you don't do this and that
okay shut the [ __ ] up yeah you know it
was what i want to say to myself because
i didn't know these things like i had a
very staunch idea about what cheating
was
right and i was like okay if somebody
cheated on me
right i'm gonna leave them immediately
and then when i got into a serious
relationship and i cared about somebody
and i'm like it's not that easy
like i said these things and when i was
in it i left this girl but i was like
yeah
it was hard though it's like why can't i
leave this girl even though i said i
would
it's because i didn't have the wisdom to
think about oh we went through so many
great things
she has so many great qualities do i
have this
do i have the balls to even let this
person go because i'm so attached to it
yeah i don't even think about [ __ ] like
that
i think the problem right now is that
more people are quick to share the
information before they actually
soak in what they just learned yeah yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying everybody
wants a package and
let me get it ready to share they
haven't even sat with it
like long enough to soak it in and
understand why this problem problem
exists yeah why this person is doing
that thing like they're not doing the
back
background checks of all this stuff
before they even share it people love
sharing [ __ ] i'm not gonna front i love
sharing [ __ ] too
yeah i do but that's that's the problem
like i'm a product of that like i can
i can feel that energy of like we got to
share this con it's the content game
you know like when do we start collin
[ __ ] content
like yeah yeah yeah con we never used to
say content i think
you know denzel washington said the best
he goes like everybody
is too quick to want to be first and
rather be right
right it's true yeah it's so true man
and that's what he was he was
criticizing media
yeah i think i saw that on the red
carpet right he said yeah like that yeah
oh [ __ ] am i like that
it made me think like am i like that and
that's why in these podcasts
you'll see hot topics i do a week later
after like the
the whole trump thing that happened
immediately i didn't really say much
about it
because and then i allowed it to rest
for a week it's not going to get as much
views
yeah but at least i'm allowed to collect
my thoughts because that's something
that's very sensitive instead of me
trying to be first
i should at least think about something
that serious before i go ahead and just
say a bunch of stuff about it right you
know
right i find more relief listening to
podcasts from people
who don't know what they're talking
about i think that's why people love
bobby
no honestly like real [ __ ] like
listening to bobby like i just
oh it's like stepping in a hot tub yeah
it's like sitting in a hot tub like oh
yes let me just
just like let me just it's like stepping
in a hot tub that's bobby's body
yeah like let me just not know [ __ ] for
like two hours
bobby's podcast yo even when we go on
his podcast like he says stuff that i'm
just
dying i'm like this guy is [ __ ] nuts
like i told him i'm like you're the most
gangster dude i've ever met in my life
because you're the only heterosexual i
know that has sucked a dick on purpose
that hasn't gone to jail
that's that's you like i i love bobby
because he has
he has he and he's an og when i mean
like he hasn't
like he doesn't know shout out i mean he
doesn't he has an experience [ __ ] i mean
the dude is og
but like what i love about bobby he has
decades of stories
of not knowing [ __ ] or not knowing
better
like yeah at that moment that's why the
stories are so [ __ ] good
you know he doesn't act like he knows
[ __ ] he like literally is the guy he's
he's like i feel like i'm him i feel
seen when i see bobby bro
you know what's where he actually feels
that way when he looks at people like us
uh because he said growing up he felt
like a an odd person like an oddball
because there weren't any other asian
people like him around he talks about
this a lot right yeah so he looks at
people like us he goes oh [ __ ] i'm not
that weird there's
[ __ ] [ __ ] up people like me too i'm
like hold on a second
[ __ ] deep throating dudes dicks for
fun i can see what he's saying you know
no bobby's the man bro cause he always
like when every time we come i see him
or something he like
gasses me up like i'm super cool like he
thinks like we're like the cool
asians or something like in his head i'm
like bro
nah like you're the coolest asian
[ __ ] that you're like at the
pinnacle yeah yeah for real this pool
always calls me fat even though he's
fatter than me now
i'm like he's like look at you fat guy
bobby's like it's weird with bobby
because he's not really fat
like he's his own thing like uh
how big is bobby bobby's bobby yeah i
can't explain what it is
is he like skinny fat fat skin i don't
know what it is his hair
he doesn't have a single [ __ ] gray in
his hair and he's like damn you're 50. i
know i thought he dyed his hair he
didn't dye his hair
yeah no he that that's why he's like a
mythical creature
you can't tell his age or nothing he's
like willow bro like
see oh there's a young or what he's
actually 96 years old dude you guys
wouldn't even [ __ ] know
well guys uh that wraps up this episode
of the genius brain podcast
shout outs to [ __ ] bobby lee you
could find dumb tell them where they can
find you
all the social media dumbfounded shout
out david so he actually featured on one
of my songs
years ago uh years ago this has to be at
least seven years ago or something like
that um
on korean jesus the intro was you if you
guys didn't know that's obvious
it's the same thing i do now yeah it's
the same exact thing he's roasting jesus
or something in it like
yeah i'm gonna go to hell for that one
like god's gonna [ __ ] play that back
so remember when you did this
i'm like it was parker's fault
[Laughter]
we'll see you all next time peace peace